die künftigen regentinnen zeigen 10
seit 28 jahren die band musiziert
provoziert experimentiert
von dana und punk beeinflusst kreisen
ihre songs meist um alltägliche
absurditäten multimedial performt
zusammengefunden haben die königinnen
1987 im rahmen der jugend und
frauenbewegung in basel
einige kamen manche gingen immer wieder
traten sie in wechselnder formation auf
die einzige die nie aus der reihe tanzte
muda mathis die kur königin erinnert
sich an den rhein fand 1988 auch
pipilotti rist geschmack zusammen mit
muda mathis besuchte sie in basel die
video fachklasse sechs jahre lang
kochten die freundinnen gemeinsam
exklusives süppchen
kleinbetriebe professionelle viele taxis
muss das heißt im nicht abgeschafft wird
liebt eigentlich wahrheiten wird die
möchtegern die stunde der augenpartie
roten schlamm werden wir endlich über
würde die stärke des freundinnen
kollektivs jeder von ihnen hat gelernt
unverkrampft mit unverschämten umzugehen
menschliches wagemutig auf die bühne
bringen
darin sind diese heldinnen des alltags
königlich
am 1